hello this is part 2 of native accent
and language learning and I wanted to go
more in detail of what I discussed
previously so the first the first part
was a general introduction on why on the
difficulties that adults face when
learning when learning a language in
general and right now I want to discuss
the five steps that I go through in
order to try to acquire a name like
accent let me first tell you that the
first step that you have to you have to
do or at least that I do is through
radical and means that a lot of courses
for example a Cemile or teach yourself
provided introduction on phonetics a
brief introduction on the mechanics of
the sounds it means that they consider
single sounds and they visualize more or
less the pronunciation so I call it
mechanic of a few things that make up
the language for example they start by
showing how vowels work and then for
example in Italian it's the typical five
vowels and then they show you how to
aggregate vowels so that means the
combination the possible combination of
vowels
for example diphthongs or diphthongs I
don't remember how you spell in English
and then for example in French is
different it did in Italian there's the
advantage that the vowels don't change
in any position even if they're with
three vowels a group of three vowels
they just stay the same and it's very
different for other languages especially
a French for example or English and then
there's consonants so not only
consonants in general and so isolated
consonants but also group of consonants
in Italian you also have double
consonants which is a peculiarity
peculiarities of ditalion language and
they not only change the way the
consonant itself is produced but also
the preceding vowel so let's end Enders
of course the combination of vowels plus
and consolate with consonants so these
vowels will be pronounced just
separately and then within a word in a
word so let's suppose that you have
taken you have done this first step that
means that you have seen how vowels
consonants and vowels plus consonants
work this is the first what I call the
first theoretical step in the sense that
it's a necessary step that you have to
go through and some of you have already
seen for example in decimal hollows
words after for the first step you the
second step that is step two is to
directly stick to the language so attack
the language so to say it means that
after the the brief introduction you
will have to read immediately the
dialogue that means the voices of native
speakers talking and interacting with
each other what do you have to do here
is to pay attention just pay attention
listen attentively to the way vowels are
pronounced and vowels and consonants are
pronounced a very important feature in
step two is to listen and read at the
same time because this action creates a
bond between a word words and sounds
which will turn out to be very useful
later
step 3 is something that few courses
provide and that's my personal they can
each which is called phonetic analysis
now the musicality of a language that I
discussed previously with the example of
pen diamo epidemiological strata is
difficult
feature not only to grasp but also to
visualize how do you visualize a
sentence well you can use tools you can
use some software's some soft programs
that actually do show you how
human voice is represented in terms of a
physical wave but this I apply this
technique directly with a very simple
tool which is a pencil and a piece of
paper I use markers what is a marker you
will see in part three little marketer
what a marker is I use a few markers in
order to visualize more or less how the
sounds how the how the sentence is
authored and in step four I will use
these guidelines that I myself created
in order to uh Terr and repeat a
sentence so very important very
important principle is that imitate a
bad pronunciation in general is the a
result of imitation without
understanding that means that a lot of
people they think they can just imitate
the native speaker while talking for
example and think that they can actually
pick up the way and die and native
speakers talk unfortunately it doesn't
work that way or some people actually do
succeed in imitating the sounds for a
long period of time then they turn out
to be very fluent speakers of that
language but for most of us
unfortunately it doesn't work that way
so very important sticking to this
principle you have to try to understand
how a sentence work so I'm talking about
mechanics of sounds in the brief
introduction and the mechanic of sounds
is visible if you for example go on
Google Translate and have them pronounce
a word but the dynamics that is the
intonation musicality whatever you want
to call it is something more difficult
that you have to try to figure out width
with and with something and I do it with
this phonetic analysis and with markers
and the fifth step is absolutely
mandatory it is for for a native like
pronunciation and it
the contact with native speakers because
as I said our brain is not a tariff
filter so it kind of sees it has gaps
and there's no way to fill in these gaps
if we are not attentive you have to be
flexible that means that you always have
to be constantly you have to be
constantly curious about what you
pronounce well and what you don't right
you could tell me
well yeah but I can't see it like I
don't know how to pronounce that I
didn't realize how this worked I can't
buy myself that's the reason why these
small gaps can be filled with a native
speaker pointing out to you the things
that you didn't understand and that did
elude you
so this is part 2 and part 3 I will
actually explain what it means to do a
phonetics perform to carry out a
phonetic analysis on a text thank you so
much for listening to me see on part 3
bye